never been about good versus the bad  it's about keeping the powerful in power  will you decided to use your infinite  powers to start a ward cold solos but  you went too far too public vigilante  maybe he lent this web videos went viral  after he killed a rising Armenian  syndicate you want a war  well now you got one with the target the  entire Armenian mob they don't like me  nobody likes you  those dudes don't play that psycho  killed my baby brother  I want the vigilante dead this one's not  gonna be pretty  I'm game let's do this man I'll go back  to work  [Music]  the gland mines and chip of left left in  the talkin if you're doing it cuz hides  and awesome  he said you're coming after me don't  bother I'm on my way  you  you